こんしゅうのざっくばらん
TeslaのFSD（自動運転）で長距離ドライブ
せんしゅう、ワシントン州のSuncadiaリゾートというところまで、二泊三日で旅行に行きました。
I-90と呼ばれる高速道路で片道約85マイル（約140キロ、渋谷から高速道路で富士吉田ぐらいの距離）。
長距離トラックが走る山道なので、普通に運転すると疲労するし眠くなりますが、今回はTeslaのFSD（自動運転）を最大限活用したので、とても楽でした。
高速道路だけでなく、自宅の駐車場を出てからリゾート地まで、運転操作としては一切、ハンドル・ブレーキ・アクセルに触らずに済みました。
普段なら疲れて眠くなるところですが、ポッドキャストや会話を楽しみながら、快適なドライブでした。
いぜんにも指摘しましたが、TeslaのFSDは日常の運転においてもすでに人間の運転にかなり近い、あるいはそれを上回るレベルに到達しつつあり、特に眠くなりやすい長距離ドライブにおいては、圧倒的に安全・安心です。
久しぶりの遠出なので、航続距離が心配でしたが、往復280キロを途中で充電する必要もなく、家に戻った時にはまだ40％も電池が残っていました。
2年前まで所有していたModel Xと比べると、Model Yは、燃費も良いし電池の容量も増えているので、この手のドライブには最適です。
実際に所有しないと理解しにくいと思いますが、電気自動車と自動運転の組み合わせは最強です。
自動運転は、現時点では私のような「アーリー・アダプター」向けのものに過ぎませんが、数年以内に誰もが欲しがる「なくてはならないもの」になり、10年を超えたあたりで、長距離トラックや高齢者が運転する自動車には「搭載が義務」になり、最終的には（インターネットやスマホのように）「なかった時代が想像できないもの」になります。
Tesla以外にも自動運転機能を導入し始めている自動車メーカーは複数あるし、エヌビディアはそこに大きなビジネスチャンスを見て、着実に駒を進めています。
WaymoとTeslaがしのぎを削るロボタクシー市場ばかりが注目を集めていますが、乗用車やトラックに搭載される自動運転機能が、自動車しじょうに与える影響は近いうちに無視できない大きさになると私は見ています。
台数ベースで見れば、ロボタクシーよりも乗用車やトラックへの搭載の方が桁違いに大きな市場なのです。
[EN]Cerebras Systems[/EN]
5月にじょうじょうしたエーアイチップベンチャー
Cerebras
に関して、少し気になるXへの投稿を目にしたので、少し調べてみました。
Cerebrasは、いぜんから私が注目してきたエーアイベンチャーの一つで、上場の半年ほど前に投資をするチャンスがあったのですが、顧客が偏りすぎているという理由で見送った経緯がある企業です。
その後、ライバルのGroqが、実質的な買収と言える形でエヌビディアに技術をライセンス供与した結果、Cerebrasがこのしじょうで勝てるチャンスはかなり薄くなったと感じていたので、5月の上場時には投資を見送りました。
しかし、その後、オープンエーアイとの契約も発表し、どうなることかと見守っていた時に、目にしたのが、オープンエーアイのエンジニアのインタビューを紹介するXへの投稿です（
オープンエーアイ内部では、Cerebras上に置いたオープンエーアイのエーアイモデルの実証実験が始まっているそうですが、あまりにもすいろんのスピードが速いため、待ち時間に他の仕事をする必要もなく、とんでもなく生産性が上がっているそうです。
なぜそんなに速いのかというと、Cerebrasのチップは通常のジーピーユーとは設計思想がまったく違うからです。
通常は円盤状のウェハー（半導体の材料）から小さなチップを大量に切り出しますが、Cerebrasは切り分けずに一枚を丸ごと巨大なチップとして使い、その上にエーアイモデルの重み（パラメータ）を載せきってしまいます。
ジーピーユーの場合、重みはチップの外のメモリ（HBM）に置かれているため、トークンを一つ生成するたびにモデル全体を読み直す必要があり、そのデータ転送の速度が上限になります。
Cerebrasにはこの外部メモリへの往復がないため、トークン生成が桁違いに速いのです。
ちなみに、オープンエーアイとの契約は以下のようなものです。
契約期間は、2028年まで（延長オプションあり）
Cerebrasは、750メガワットの推論向けの計算能力を提供（2ギガワットまで拡張可能）
契約きぼは二百億ドル超
オープンエーアイは、十億ドルを運転資金として提供
オープンエーアイは、Cerebrasの最大約10パーセントの株主になれるワラント（あらかじめ決めた価格で株を買える権利）を取得
オープンエーアイは、Cerebrasからエーアイチップを購入するのではなく、Cerebrasのチップを使った計算能力を購入する、という点が重要です。
つまり、この部分だけ見ると、マイクロソフトと肩を並べる形になるのです。
Cerebrasはこれまでデータセンターの構築に関しては、大株主で最大の顧客でもあるG42（アブダビ政府が育てたエーアイ国家戦略会社）に任せてきました。
大株主であるG42がCerebrasからエーアイチップを購入し、データセンターを構築した上で、その計算能力をCerebrasが外販するという、スキームです。
オープンエーアイ向けの750メガワットきぼのエーアイデータセンターを構築する資金を、Cerebras一社が負担するのは重すぎるので、そこにG42が参加してくるかどうかは不明ですが、オープンエーアイが期待する通りのデータセンターを構築することができれば、大きな売り上げにつながります。
逆に言えば、Cerebrasのリスクはもはや「契約を取れるか」ではなく「取った契約を期限内に建て切れるか」に移ったということです。
ちなみに、Cerebrasのすいろんの速さに関しては、Cognition（エーアイコーダー、Devinを提供するエーアイベンチャー）の研究者もベタ褒めしており（
）、これを一度体験したら、もう元には戻れないだろうことは簡単に想像できます。
デザイナー向けのサービスでAdobeに挑戦しているFigmaも、エーアイニーズの40％をCerebrasに流しているそうです（
）。
この「40％」という半端な数字が、とても興味深いと感じました。
従量課金ではなく、計算容量を前もって購入する契約（リザーブ型）だからです。
つまり普段から確実に必要な分（ベース）だけを固定額でCerebrasから買い、それを超えるじゅようが出た時だけ（ピーク）従量課金の別のサービスに流す、という設計なのです。
これはCerebrasにとっては巨額なせつびとうしの回収が前もって読めることを意味し、Figmaにとってはその分だけ単価が下がる。
まさにwin-winなので、こんごはこんな形の契約が増えるのかも知れません。
CerebrasはさらにAMDとのパートナーシップも発表していますが（
[EN]AMD is betting big on splitting AI workloads across different silicon[/EN]
）、技術的には（エヌビディアが買収した）Groqと同様に、（大規模言語モデルのベースである）トランスフォーマーを動かす際に、（コンテキストを読み込む）prefillはジーピーユーで行いつつ、（トークンを生成する）decodeはCerebrasのチップで高速に行うという点は注目に値します。
つまり、これから起ころうとしている「高速推論」の戦いは、「エヌビディア+Groq vs. AMD+Cerebras」の構造に、それにグーグルの次世代ティーピーユーを加えた「三つ巴」の戦いになると考えて良いのだと思います。
エヌビディアからGroqベースのアクセラレータが発売される時期はまだ未定ですが、その性能・タイミング次第では、こんごCerebrasが大きな役割を果たす可能性は十分にあると感じました。
（注：私はこの記事を書きはじめた時点では、Cerebrasの株は保有していませんでしたが、書いているうちに欲しくなって、少しですが購入しました。
私がかつて投資を見送った理由は「G42に顧客が偏りすぎている」ことでしたが、オープンエーアイ、Figma、Cognitionという顧客が並んだ今、その理由は消えつつあります。
まだ赤字の会社なので、大きく投資する気にはなりませんが、少し株を持って「自分ごと」にする価値はあると感じたのです）。
MulmoTerminal
このメルマガでは、ここまで
MulmoClaude
のことをなんどか紹介してきましたが、実は並行して、
MulmoTerminal
というアプリケーションも開発しています。
きっかけは、アンソロピックによる、ある課金ポリシー変更のアナウンスでした。
Claude Codeは通常、オーエスのターミナルアプリの中で対話型で走らせるタイプのアプリケーションですが、"-p オプション"を使うと、他のアプリからエーピーアイのように使うことができ、MulmoClaudeもそれを活用しています。
この方法だと、エーピーアイを使った場合と違って従量課金にはならず、月額の固定料金（$20、$100、$200の三つのプランが存在）だけで、さまざまなことができるようになるからです。
しかし、OpenClawというアプリがこの機能を使うことにより、大量にトークンを消費し始めたため、それに悲鳴をあげたアンソロピックが、「"-p" オプションでの実行を従量課金の対象にする」とアナウンスしたのです。
その後、開発者たちからの反発などを受けて、従量課金への変更は「延期」されましたが、いつ変更されても良いようにと準備のために開発し始めたのがMulmoTerminalです。
MulmoTerminalは、"-p オプション"は使わず、（マイクロソフトのVSCodeと同様に）実際のターミナル・エミュレータの中でClaude Codeを動かします。
そのため、見た目はチャットアプリというよりは開発環境に近づいてしまいますが、私のような開発者には逆に心地よい環境でもあります。
そこで、
MulmoClaudeは一般ユーザー向け
MulmoTerminalは開発者向け
というポジショニングで住み分けを行いつつ、並行してかいはつを進めることにしました。
そして、私自身は、MulmoClaudeで培った機能をMulmoTerminalにも搭載することに集中し、共同開発者の有本氏には「MulmoTerminalを開発者にとってなくてはならないものにして」と依頼したところ、当初想定もしていなかった「とんでもない進化」が起こり、私にとっても「なくてはならないアプリ」に進化してしまいました。
開発者でない人にその素晴らしさを説明するのは簡単ではありませんが、さいきんの開発者の一番の悩みは、複数のターミナル画面で並行してエーアイを使ったかいはつをしていると、混乱して間違った指示を出したり、必要以上にエーアイを待たせてしまうことにあります。
私の場合、ことしの2月ぐらいまでは、VSCodeやCursorのようなIDEの中でClaude Codeと1対1で対話し、エーアイが生成したコードを確認しながらソフトウェアを開発していましたが、さいきんは、エーアイの進化により、コードを見る必要がほとんどなくなったし、プランさえさいしょにしっかりと作れば、あとはエーアイに任せっぱなしにできるようになりました。
結果として、複数のターミナルを開いて複数の作業を並行して進めることが可能になりました。
ところが、そこでボトルネックになったのが私自身の認知能力の限界で、「このターミナルでは何をさせていたのだろう？
」と悩んだり、エーアイが私の指示を待っているのに気が付かずに待たせてしまったり、最悪の場合、あるエーアイに出すはずだった指示を、別のエーアイに出してしまう、などのミスが生じるようになりました。
別の言い方をすれば、さいきんのソフトウェア・エンジニアの仕事は、それぞれが別の目的で飛行場に発着する飛行機に対して適切なタイミングで指示を出す管制官のような役割で、そこで良い仕事ができないと、進化したエーアイによってもたらされた生産性の向上の恩恵を十分に受けることができなくなってしまうのです。
MulmoTerminalには、グリッド・ビューと呼ばれる複数のターミナルを表示する画面がありますが、これがまさに「管制官向けのダッシュボード」のような役割を果たし、どのターミナルでエーアイがどの仕事をしており、人間からの指示待ちなのかどうかなども一目で分かります。
さらに、MulmoClaude向けに作ったリモートアクセス機能をさらに拡張し、パソコンから離れていてもかいはつの進捗状況がリアルタイムで把握できるし、指示を待っているエーアイに対してリモートで指示を出せるようになりました。
ちなみに、私は少し前までは、メルマガの執筆はVSCodeで行い、誤字脱字は妻やChatGPTに確認してもらうという手法で行っていましたが、こんしゅう号からは、MulmoTerminalの中で執筆を行い、その場で、Claude Codeに誤字脱字を見つけて修正もしてもらう、という手法に切り替えました。
同じ画面で、開発も並行して進められるので、とても重宝しています。
私の目に留まった記事
[EN]The next chapter of our AI momentum[/EN]
グーグルのシーイーオー（最高経営責任者）であるSundar Pichaiと、エーアイ研究部門グーグル DeepMindを率いるDemis Hassabisが連名で発表した、エーアイ部門の大がかりな体制変更のお知らせですが、その中で創業初期からグーグルを支えてきた伝説的なエンジニアたちの退社も明かされました。
体制変更の中身は、Hassabisが日々の運営から一歩引いて、グーグル DeepMindの会長とAlphabet全体のChief Scientist（最高科学責任者）に就くというものです。
空いた実務の指揮は、Koray KavukcuogluがSVP（上級副社長）に昇格して引き継ぎ、Geminiというエーアイモデルの開発、最先端の研究、そしてGeminiアプリまでを見ることになります。
Hassabis自身は「人類史の転換点に来ている」と述べ、AGI（汎用人工知能。
人間と同等以上に幅広い仕事をこなせるエーアイ）をどう正しく作るかという長期的な課題に集中する、としています。
そして同じ発表の中で、Jeff DeanとSanjay Ghemawatの2人が27年間の在籍を終えて退社することが告げられました。
Jeff Deanは社員番号30番、つまり社員が25人ほどだった頃に入社した人物で、大量のデータを分散しょりするMapReduce、大規模なデータベースのBigtable、エーアイ開発ツールのTensorFlow、エーアイ計算専用チップのティーピーユーなど、今のグーグルとインターネットの土台にあたる技術の多くを作ってきました。
Sanjay Ghemawatはその長年の相棒で、ペアプログラミング（2人でひとつの画面を見ながらプログラムを書くこと）をすることで知られた組み合わせです。
Deanが自身のXへの投稿で明かした新会社は、Discovery Loopといい、共同創業者はグーグルの発表にあった2人だけではありませんでした。
Jeff Dean（シーイーオー）
[EN]Sanjay Ghemawat（Google Senior Fellow。
同社の最上位の技術職）[/EN]
[EN]Quoc Le（Google Brainの創設メンバー）[/EN]
[EN]Oriol Vinyals（Google DeepMindの副社長でGemini開発の中心人物）[/EN]
とても大きな動きです。
ノーベル賞の受賞者でもあるDemis Hassabisは、純粋な研究者であり、彼をエーアイ部門のトップに置いていたからこそ、優秀な研究者にとって魅力的な会社であり、世界の最先端を走り続けることができました。
しかし、ビジネス面ではオープンエーアイ、アンソロピックの二社による事実上の寡占状態を許してしまっており、今回の組織変更はそれに対処するためのものであり、会社としての大きな方向転換であるとも言えます。
それだけでも十分に大きなニュースなのに、そこに、これまでグーグルを技術面で支えてきたJeff DeanとSanjay Ghemawatが辞めてしまうことは、大きなショックですが、これもグーグルが会社として新しいフェーズに入ろうとしていることを示す証拠なのかも知れません。
彼らは、Discovery Loopという新しい会社で「科学の実験そのものの自動化」を行うことに注力するそうです。
Alphabetからは法的に独立した別会社で、Radical VenturesとKhosla Venturesから資金を調達して作られた公益重視型の株式会社（利益だけでなく社会的な目的も定款に掲げる会社）で、Alphabet自身も出資に加わっている上に、クラウド・パートナーとして協業を続けるそうです。
発表当日のAlphabet株は5パーセント下落しました。
グーグルの強さは技術力にあるわけで、今回の発表は、投資家たちにとっては大きなショックだったのでしょう。
[EN]Muse Spark 1.2 just cracked the top 5 on the Vals Index[/EN]
メタの新しいエーアイモデル「Muse Spark 1.2」が、第三者機関Vals エーアイのランキングで総合5位に入りながら、テスト1回あたりのコストは$0.69と、上位5モデルの中で圧倒的に安かった、という報告です。
上位モデルの実力差が縮まる中、競争の軸が「どれが一番賢いか」から「同じ賢さをいくらで買えるか」へ移りつつあることを示しています。
Vals エーアイは、エルエルエム（大規模言語モデル。
ChatGPTのような、文章を理解して生成するエーアイ）に金融やソフトウェア開発といった実務に近い課題を解かせて採点する評価機関です。
その総合成績表が「Vals Index」で、成績と一緒に「その成績を出すのに実際いくらかかったか」まで公表されるのが特徴です。
上位はこうなっています。
モデル
提供元
スコア
テスト1回のコスト
Claude Fable 5
アンソロピック
75.14パーセント
$5.16
Claude Opus 5
アンソロピック
74.82パーセント
$8.54
Kimi K3
Moonshot エーアイ
74.70パーセント
$2.34
ジーピーティー-5.6 Sol
オープンエーアイ
73.12パーセント
$7.46
Muse Spark 1.2
メタ
71.88パーセント
$0.69
安さの理由は、エーピーアイ（外部のプログラムからエーアイを呼び出す仕組み）の料金そのものが低く設定されていることです。
トークン（エーアイが文章を扱う最小単位。
単語のかけらのようなもの）100万個あたりの価格を並べると、
Muse Spark 1.2：入力$1.25 / 出力$4.25
Kimi K3：入力$3 / 出力$15
ジーピーティー-5.6 Sol：入力$5 / 出力$30
[EN]Claude Fable 5：入力$10 / 出力$50[/EN]
特に効いているのが出力側の$4.25で、同クラスのモデルの中央値$10の半分以下。
1位のFable 5とのスコア差は3ポイントほどしかないのに、費用はKimi K3の約3分の1、ジーピーティー-5.6 SolやClaude Opus 5の10分の1以下という構図です。
メタはさらに、「Contributor（貢献者）」という別料金を用意しています。
入力$0.10 / 出力$0.20と標準の12〜21分の1ですが、条件は「入力した内容とエーアイの回答をメタが製品改善に使うことを認める」こと。
仕事のコードや機密情報を扱う用途では使えず、1分あたりのリクエスト数も標準の50分の1に絞られています。
なおVals エーアイが測った$0.69は標準料金での数字なので、この割引とは別の話です。
この価格設定の背景には、メタの巨額のせつびとうしがあります。
同社のせつびとうしは年$130-145billion（約20兆円）に達するいっぽう、フリーキャッシュフロー（自由に使える現金）は前年同期の八十五億ドルから七億八千四百万ドルまで落ち込みました。
余った計算資源を値引きに回し、その代わりに「コンパイルやテストで正誤を自動判定できる」という学習データとして最も価値の高いプログラミングのやり取りを集める――無料サービスとユーザーデータを交換してきたメタの従来の手法を、エーアイ開発に持ち込んだ形です。
ただし安さの中身は「単価が安い」だけで、効率がいいわけではありません。
Artificial Analysisの計測では、Muse Spark 1.2は前バージョンより1問あたりの出力トークンが36パーセント増えており、同社の指標で見た1問あたりのコストはむしろ上がっています。
Llama4の失敗いらい、フロンティア・モデル競争からしばらく脱落していたメタですが、このMuse Spark 1.2で一気に追い上げてきた感があり、こんごの展開が楽しみです。
私も早速、MuseをMulmoTerminalから起動できるようにして、コードを書かせる実験を開始しました。
1日ほど触った感覚では、Claude Opus 5にはまだ少し負けているように感じます。
コードの生成はそれなりにやってくれますが、Opus 5にコード・レビューをさせると、複数の問題が見つかりました。
[EN]Power 2026: Electricity Pricing in the Age of AI[/EN]
元シタデル（世界最大級のヘッジファンド）で電力・ガスを担当していたクオンツ（数理モデルでしじょうを分析する専門家）のNeel Somani氏が公開した、「エーアイ時代の電力価格」の入門解説です。
エーアイの話題は半導体とメモリーに集中しがちですが、本当のボトルネックは電力であり、その電力しじょうの仕組みが投資家にもエンジニアにもほとんど理解されていないため、まとめて解説する、という趣旨で書かれています。
まず前提として、データセンターは既に米国の電力消費の約5パーセントを占めており、その消費量は2年ごとに倍増しています。
このペースが続けば、2030年代半ばには米国の総発電量を上回る計算になります。
電力しじょうでは、価格は「限界費用」（追加であと1メガワットアワー作るのにかかる費用）で決まります。
ISO（独立系統運用機関。
地域の電力網を管理し、需給を一致させる組織）が、発電所を安い順（再エネ・原子力 → 石炭 → ガスのピーク電源）に並べて必要な分だけ動かし、さいごに動いた一番高い発電所の費用が、その地域全体の価格になる、という仕組みです。
送電線には容量の上限があるため、場所によって価格が変わり（LMP＝地点別限界価格）、混雑した場所ほど電気は高くなります。
エーアイ向けデータセンターにとって、電力の壁は三つに整理されます。
発電所そのものの不足。
新設には数年かかる
送電線の制約。
ニューヨーク州北部には安い原発の電気があるのに、電気代の高いマンハッタンへ送れない
接続待ちの行列（インターコネクション・キュー）。
系統への接続審査になんねんもかかる
さらに、データセンターは建設資金を借りるために「長期で決まった価格の電気」が必要です。
相場が$10〜150/メガワットアワーの間で乱高下するしじょうのままでは、銀行が融資できないからです。
そこでPPA（電力購入契約。
何年分の電気を1メガワットアワーいくらで買うかを先に決める長期契約）や、ヘッジ（価格変動を打ち消す金融取引）が使われます。
系統への接続を待たずに敷地内に発電所を建てる「ビハインド・ザ・メーター」方式や、テキサスのように容量しじょうを持たず、需給が逼迫すると価格が$5,000/メガワットアワーまで跳ね上がることで新設を促す「エネルギーオンリー市場」など、地域ごとに設計思想も異なります。
著者の結論は、電力事業の経済性そのものは明快で、当面は発電所を作ることも電力しじょうで取引することも儲かる、というものです。
ただし本当の制約は建設スピードと送電線であり、タービンメーカー（GE Vernova、Siemens、三菱）が数年の受注残を抱えていること、そして送電線の許認可に時間がかかることを最優先で解消すべきだと提言しています。
上の、電力価格の決め方の話はとても良い勉強になりました。
発送電の分離が進んだ国では、こんな形で発電の最適化が行われるのです。
日本の場合は、配電網がその地域の電力会社の配下にあるため、電力が余ると太陽光パネルからの電力を捨てるなどの経済的に不合理なことが行われ、それを是正する進化圧が働きません。
[EN]The Shape of Things to Come, Part 1: The Continuous Thunderdome[/EN]
大量のエーアイエージェントを24時間動かし続けている開発者が、「1年後には人間によるコードレビューもCI/CD（コードを変更するたびに自動でテストして本番に反映する仕組み）も成立しなくなる」と予言した記事で、エーアイによるかいはつが現場のやり方そのものを作り変える様子が具体的な数字とともに描かれているので紹介します。
筆者のSteve Yeggeは、自分が30年前に作った多人数参加型オンラインゲーム「Wyvern」のかいはつを、Wheelhouseと名付けた自作の管理システムでエーアイエージェントの群れに任せています。
動かしているのは18体の「クルー」と呼ばれるまとめ役のエージェントと、その下で実作業をするエーアイの集団。
月額$200のMaxアカウントを個人用とは別に12個（合計13個）持ち、フルに活用（月額$2,800、税込、約42万円）し、月に約690億トークンを消費し（その96パーセントはキャッシュ）、1日に175回以上のコミット（コードの変更をまとめて記録する単位）が生まれ、順番待ちの行列が150件を超えることも珍しくないといいます。
定額ではなく、従量課金だと月額$87,000（約1,300万円）になる計算です。
この速度になると、従来のやり方が次々に壊れます。
まず人間によるコードレビューは、エーアイの生産速度に人間の目が追いつかないため不可能です。
次にCI/CDも破綻します。
1件ずつ順番にテストしていては、膨大なコミットを処理しきれないからです。
そこで筆者が採用したのが、順番待ちをやめて全部のコミットを一気にmainブランチへ流し込むという乱暴な方式。
壊れたらエージェントの群れに一斉に原因を突き止めさせて、その場で直させます。
開発以外にも常駐型のエージェントが必要になり、
サーバーの安定運用を見張る役
デプロイの様子を監視する役
投稿内容の健全性をチェックする役
ユーザーからの要望をGitHubの課題票やゲーム内のチャットで受け取り、危険の少ないものはエーアイが勝手にじっそうして反映してしまう仕組み
などが、人間が見ていない間も動き続けているそうです。
ソフトウェアの開発プロセスは、ここ半年で根本的に変わりました。
私はここまで極端なやり方は採用していませんが、人間によるコードレビューはすでに不可能で、CIテストがボトルネックになっているのは事実です。
しかし、さすがにコードレビューとCIテストの両方を廃止するわけにも行かないので、悩ましいところです。
[EN]Forward deployed engineers are the AI industry's latest talent obsession[/EN]
エーアイ業界で今もっとも取り合いになっている人材は、最先端のモデルを作る研究者ではなく、企業の現場に入り込んでエーアイを実際に使えるようにする「フォワード・デプロイド・エンジニア（FDE）」だ、という記事です。
エーアイの勝負が「良いモデルを持っているか」から「それを現場で成果に変えられるか」に移ったことを象徴する動きなので、紹介します。
FDEとは、エーアイを提供する側の会社から顧客企業の現場に「出向く」形で常駐し、その企業の業務を理解した上で、エーアイを組み込んだ仕組みを一緒に作り上げるエンジニアのことです。
この働き方をさいしょに確立したのはPalantirで、同社は自社のソフトを納品するだけでなく、エンジニアを顧客の現場に送り込んで業務そのものを作り替えることで成長してきました。
今その手法が、エーアイ業界全体に広がっています。
記事によると、じゅようの伸び方は異常です。
2026年の初めにはFDEの採用を計画していた企業は全体の5〜10パーセントでしたが、年の半ばには70パーセントに跳ね上がり、年末までにじゅようは2,100パーセント増になると予測されています。
採用支援会社の創業者Jeff Christian氏は「これほどの速さは見たことがない。
企業が夏の真っ最中に採用している」と語っています。
米国内でFDEと呼べる人材はおよそ17,000人いるものの、業界が本当に欲しがっている層――業界知識と現場での信頼、そして実際にエーアイを動かした経験の3つを兼ね備え、数千万ドルきぼの投資対効果を出せる人材は、全米で2,000人程度しかいない、というのが実情だそうです。
動きは各社に及んでいます。
アンソロピックと組んだChris Taylor氏の新会社Ode、オープンエーアイの導入支援部門、そしてFDEの人数を10倍に増やす必要があると語る大手コンサル各社。
保険、フィンテック（金融とITを組み合わせたサービス）、医療、ゲームといった業種の事業会社も自前で採り始めており、Palantirの技術を買う目的が実はそのFDE人材へのアクセスだった、という例まであるといいます。
外注ではなく社内チームを作りたがるのは、自社の業務ノウハウをエーアイ企業に渡してしまうと、それを競合他社向けに使われかねないという警戒感からです。
Taylor氏も記事の中で指摘していますが、FDEの質には大きなバラつきがあり、「FDE特需」に便乗した「なんちゃってFDE」が増えていることも事実なようです。
これまで、じっそうを下請け・孫請けに任せる「ゼネコンスタイル」がいっぱん的だった日本のIT業界に、FDEの仕事をこなせる人が育っているかは分かりませんが、顧客のニーズを聞き出す「上流」にいる人たちが「下請けの代わりにエーアイに仕事を任せる」ことが出来れば、仕事は回るはずです。
日本のIT業界にとって一番大きな問題は、「人月工数ビジネスモデル」からの脱却です。
エーアイを効率よく使うと、生産効率は大きく上がりますが、人月工数という点から言えば売り上げが下がってしまうことを意味します。
これまでのように「アプリを納入したら終わり」ではなく、作り出した価値に応じた「成果報酬型」のビジネスモデルに切り替える必要があります。
[EN]Former Nebius employee on NVIDIA and the neoclouds[/EN]
エヌビディアとネオクラウド（エヌビディアのジーピーユーを大量に買って、エーアイ向けの計算能力を時間貸しする新興のクラウド事業者）の力関係が、いま急速にエヌビディア有利に傾いている、という元Nebius社員へのインタビューの要約です。
話の出発点は、エヌビディアがSharonAIやFirmusといったネオクラウドと結んだ「レベニューシェア型」の提携です。
これは、ジーピーユーを売り切るのではなく、そのジーピーユーが生む売上をエヌビディアが分け合う仕組みです。
この元社員によれば、この提携は新しいビジネスモデルの発明というより、Firmusが資金繰りに苦しみ、SharonAIが顧客集めと出資者集めに苦戦していた、という弱みから生まれたものだと言います。
その結果として、ネオクラウド側はこのモデルを歓迎していない、というのが彼の見立てです。
理由は二つあり、
主導権をエヌビディアが完全に握る構図であること
大量購入による値引きが効かず、ジーピーユーの実質的な調達価格が高くなること
エヌビディアとネオクラウドの摩擦は、業界最大手のCoreWeaveとの間でも起きているとされます。
CoreWeaveが、必要な数のジーピーユーをエヌビディアが納入してくれないことに不満を持ち、別のASIC（特定の用途に絞って専用設計したチップ）メーカーに乗り換えるとまで言ったことで、エヌビディアとの関係がギクシャクしているそうです。
ちなみに、この記事を読んで思い出したのが、ゲーム端末向けのエヌビディアのビジネスモデルです。
ソニー、マイクロソフト、任天堂などのゲーム端末メーカーは、端末そのものでは大きな利益を上げず、ゲームの売上で利益を上げる構造なため、エヌビディアもそれに合わせ、チップそのものは製造コストに近い価格で提供し、ゲームの売り上げのいちぶをレベニューシェアの形で受け取ることにしたそうです。
その他のヘッドライン
「私の目に留まった記事」の紹介から漏れた記事を一行で紹介するコーナーです。
[EN]LLMs reward expertise[/EN]
: エーアイをうまく使うために本当に必要なのは「プロンプトの書き方」ではなく、その分野の深い知識だ、と主張するエンジニアのブログ記事。
[EN]Situational Awareness' portfolio sinks 67% in July on AI stock rout, letter shows[/EN]
: オープンエーアイ退社後に「
[EN]Situational Awareness[/EN]
」という長編の論文をネット上に公開し注目を浴びたLeopold Aschenbrenner氏が運営するヘッジファンドが、7月の半導体株の急落でポートフォリオの価値を67パーセントも減らした話。
[EN]Oregon-based startup Panthalassa is developing floating AI data centers powered by wave energy.[/EN]
: オレゴン州のベンチャー企業、
Panthalassa
が開発している、波の力を使って発電し、海水で冷却する、海洋データセンターの紹介です。
直感的にはとても良いアイデアのように思えますが、最終的にはコストの勝負になるので、是非とも頑張って欲しいと思います。
質問コーナー
【質問】
いつもメルマガを楽しみに拝読しております。
全くの初心者ながらMulmoClaudeでメールや予定の管理をし、大変重宝しています。
本当に便利な時代になりましたね。
先日、映画の評価コレクションを作り、おすすめを提案してくれる機能を作ってもらったのですが、中島さんのようにポスター画像をサムネイルできれいに並べて表示する機能を追加しようとしたところ、うまく表示されず困っております。
もしお時間があれば、原因に心当たりがないか教えていただけますと幸いです。
《回答》
MulmoClaudeは、これまでのアプリや開発環境とは大きく違うため戸惑うことも多いとは思いますが、1度のリクエストで期待した通りのものが作られることは滅多にないので、追加して欲しい機能や使い勝手の悪い部分を指摘して、（MulmoClaudeの中で動いている）エーアイに直させるのが一番です。
まずはポスター画像がちゃんと追加されているかどうか確認し、追加されていないようであれば追加するようにリクエストし、その上で、「ポスター画像を中心にしたグリッドビューで表示して」のように頼んでみてください。
【質問】
MulmoClaudeで趣味の犬の競技関連のアプリを作成中です。
書式がとてもビジーな競技の出陳申込書PDFをダウンロードして印刷し、手書きで何枚も記入するのがとても面倒だったのですが、MulmoClaudeと会話しながら、PDFへ別途登録済み情報を自動挿入し、申込書を作成するコレクションが出来上がりました。
これまでもVS Code＋Claude Codeで趣味のかいはつを行っており、エーアイの能力には驚かされていたのですが、今回MulmoClaudeを使い始めて、中島さんのおっしゃる“エーアイネイティブなアプリ”という意味がようやく理解できました。
MulmoClaudeもいわゆるコーディングの自動化の類との理解は、まったく浅薄でした。
“エーアイアシスタント”の意味もとてもよく理解しました。
もう少し機能を追加・リファインできたら、犬の競技仲間にも広められればと思うのですが、まだ、動作環境の用意はITに全くの素人では難しいと感じるので、（勿論Claude Pro以上？
のサブスクが必要なことはありますが）MulmoClaude利用方法の一層の簡便化と発展に期待します。
中島さんのおっしゃる“エーアイのリソースじゅようは益々増大する”ということも、時代がこのようなエーアイネイティブなアプリが主体になるのであれば、当然だと思いました。
《回答》
こんなコメントをいただけると、開発者として嬉しい限りです。
私もせんしゅう、遊びに来ている孫のために算数の問題をMulmoClaude上で作りました。
それぞれの生徒に、その子がギリギリ分かる範囲の問題集をカスタムで作るなんてことは、一昔前には想像もできなかったようなことが可能になったのは本当に凄いことだと思います。
【質問】
40代の病院薬剤師です。
プログラミングは未経験ですが、Claude Codeで仕事用だけでなくプライベート用のツールをばいぶコーディングで作りまくっています。
さいしょに作った本邦未承認薬を識別するためのQRコード作成ツールは、製作3時間で月30時間の作業が消えました。
ちなみにこのさいしょのツールが一番簡単に作れましたが、一番作業時間を削る結果になりました。
ただ、医療は閉ざされた世界で、職場ではエーアイに課金している人すらほとんど見かけません。
自分が早いというより、たまたま外の風に先に当たっただけだと思っています。
さすがにエーアイの認知度は医療業界でも高まっていますが、それでも、この業界が変わるまでには数年かかりそうです。
中島さんはネットでもスマホでも、本物の「早すぎた側」をなんども経験されてきたはずです。
波が来るまでの数年間、武器を磨く以外に何を仕込んでおくべきでしょうか。
波が来たとき、勝った人と「ただ早かっただけの人」を分けたものは何だったのでしょうか？
ご教示いただければ幸いです。
《回答》
「月30時間の作業」を無くしてしまうツールには大きな価値がありますが、もっと大きな価値は、そんなツールを作るプロセスで得た「経験」にあります。
今のように変化の激しい時代には、自ら「（新しい技術を活用して）価値を作り出すプロセスを経験する」ことが何よりもたいせつで、常にそれを重視して仕事をしていれば、それを経験していない人たちと比べて、優位な立場に立つことが可能です。
そんなプロセスで作り出したものの価値を理解してもらえない・認めてもらえない、ことはしばしばありますが、それにガッカリして手を動かすことを辞めるのは長い目で見て自分にとって損です。
理解してもらえるまで努力する、理解してもらえる人に対して提供する、時代が追いつくまで待ってから提供する、など色々と対処する方法はあります。
私の場合「誰よりもさいしょにしじょうに出したけど成功しなかったもの」は沢山あります。
PhotoShareは、世界初のスマホ向けの写真共有サービスで、当初はSNSカテゴリーでトップを走っていましたが、投資家から資金を集めて広告モデルに振り切ったInstagramに一気に抜かれてしまいました。
縦型動画をさくさくと見ることができるVeemobというアプリを誰よりも先にリリースしましたが、これも、後発のTikTokにしじょうを席巻されてしまいました。
色々と反省すべき点はありますが、エンジニアとしては常に思いっきり刺激的な人生を歩めているし、失敗も含めたそんなプロセスからも数多くのことを学んでいます。
作った後がたいせつであり、良いビジネス・パートナーに出会うことも重要だと思います。
まずはあなたが作ったものに価値を見出してくれる「理解者」を一人でも二人でも作ることから始めたらどうでしょうか？
【質問】
中島さんはいぜんメルマガで 「韓国企業で株を持ちたいと前から思っているのは、Samsung、SK Hynix、Hyundaiの三社」とおっしゃっていましたが、その理由をおしえていただけますか？
サムスンはHBMとファウンダリ、SKはHBM、ヒュンダイはヒューマノイドに注目ということでしょうか？
また、サムスンとSKはメモリ株ですが仮に中島さんが保有したとしたらガチホでしょうか？
《回答》
ご指摘のとおりで、私は韓国企業に投資しているイーティーエフを半年ほど前に購入し、長期保有する予定です。
個別株は購入が難しいので手を出していませんが、もし、個別に買えるのであれば、サムスンとヒュンダイの株を購入してガチホするだろうと思います。
SKも良い会社ですが、メモリしじょうは乱高下するので、タイミングが難しいと感じています。
【質問】
MulmoClaudeをじっそうしたので、さっそくいろいろ試してみようと思いますが、通常のClaude利用との使い分けに悩んでいます。
もともと自分のClaudeには、業務上で使うさまざまなルーチン作業をスキル化していました。
MulmoClaudeに移行してコレクション機能でアプリケーション化することは、トークンを使用せずルーチン作業できることがメリットなのでしょうか。
何をMulmoClaudeでアプリケーション化するか、何をスキルのまま使うか判断がつかず、結局ClaudeのCoWorkを使いがちなので質問させていただきました。
ご回答どうぞよろしくお願いします。
《回答》
MulmoClaudeのコレクション機能は、一連のデータを扱うスタイルのアプリケーションを、エルエルエムにとって作りやすく、ユーザーにとってマネージしやすくすることを目指して作ったハーネス（馬具から来た言葉）です。
Claude Codeを使って自分でアプリを作り、マネージもできるのであれば（＝馬具のない馬を乗りこなせるのであれば）、無理にMulmoClaudeを使う必要はありません。
イメージとしては、Claude Codeが馬、でMulmoClaudeが気楽に乗馬を楽しみたい人向けの馬具だと考えていただければ良いと思います。
このメルマガの冒頭に書きましたが、既にClaude Codeを使いこなせるエンジニア向けに、MulmoTerminalというアプリも用意しているので、そちらも是非ともお試しください。
普段は馬具なしでClaude Codeを使い、必要な時だけ（MulmoClaudeと同様の）馬具を使えるのがMulmoTerminalです。
【質問】
こんしゅう号で、エーアイがコードを書く速度が上がった結果、ご自身がボトルネックになっていると感じる、と書かれていました。
その一節が、私がここ数カ月考えていたことと重なったので、質問させてください。
（中略）
Q. 中島さんが感じておられる「自分がボトルネック」の正体は、考えたり作ったりする速度ではなく、「何を作るか」「何をたいせつにするか」を決める部分にあるのではないでしょうか。
《回答》
考える速度の問題ではなく、純粋に私が他のことをしていたり、他のエーアイと対話をしている結果、しばしば、エーアイを待たせてしまうことにあります。
エーアイが私を待っているということは、雇った社員が何もせずにいるのと同等なので、私が（生産性の）ボトルネックになったように感じるのです。
【質問】
MulmoClaudeについての質問です。
現在はClaude Codeのみでしか動かせませんが、CODEXでも動かせるようになる可能性はございますか？
私自身Claudecodeの月額200ドルのプランを使っていましたが、CODEXのほうが使い勝手と私の仕事との相性がよくClaudecodeは20ドルのプランにダウングレードしたからです。
MulmoClaudeを使うとClaude Codeの従量課金がかかってしまうのですが、定額プランの範囲内で使えるのでしょうか？
《回答》
MulmoClaudeは、現時点では、Claude Codeしか動かせません。
Codexを使うのであればMulmoTerminalをお使いください。
MulmoClaudeを使っても月額課金の枠内である限り、従量課金にはなりません。
【質問】
せんしゅうから企業の決算報告を紹介してかれていますが、とてもおもしろいので、決算がないときにも分析してもらいたいです。
毎週1社でも面白いと思います。
よろしくお願いします
《回答》
フィードバック、ありがとうございます。
決算発表は四半期ごとなので、毎週というのは難しいですが、可能な時には書きたいと思います。
【質問】
いぜん、エーアイとの対話フェーズから、エーアイに任せるフェーズへ移る際には、エーアイが持ち合わせていない「何がたいせつなのか」を人間が先に決めることが重要だとご回答いただき、ありがとうございました。
エーアイがますます賢くなり、任せられる範囲が広がる中でも、人間が決して手放してはならない判断の軸を示すお話に、はっとさせられました。
こんごエーアイを使い続ける上での指針にしたいと思っています。
7月7日号では、MulmoClaudeを「メルマガの執筆準備」にも活用されていると書かれていました。
こんしゅう号で、エーアイにコードを書かせながらメルマガを執筆する難しさに触れられていたことをきっかけに、いぜんから気になっていた点をお伺いしたいと思いました。
中島様は、メルマガ制作において、エーアイに任せる「執筆準備」と、ご自身で行う「執筆そのもの」の間に、どのような基準で線を引いておられるのでしょうか。
《回答》
模索中ですが、現時点では、
どのトピック・記事を書くかを決めるのは私の役割
調査や記事の要約はエーアイの役割
それをベースに記事を書くのは私の役割（私のコメントは全て手書き）。
誤字・脱字の修正、事実確認等はエーアイ
分かりやすさの確認は私の妻
という役割分担です。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。